il était l'homme à battre un traître
dans la bouche même de donald trump et
pourtant eduardo donne pourrait être
gracié par le président américain exilé
en russie depuis 2013
il avait dénoncé la même année la
surveillance massive des communications
et d'internet aux etats-unis et dans
plusieurs autres pays du monde
l'informaticien américains de la nasa
avait découvert par hasard un document
secret point de départ de son enquête
une enquête qui va le conduire le 6 juin
2013 a contacté deux personnes laura
poitras documentaliste et glenn green
world journaliste au guardian
objectif pour lui révéler au grand jour
ce scandale d'état lié à l'aîné sa mise
sur écoute de nombreux dirigeants
étrangers dont d'anciens présidents
français tels que nicolas sarkozy
collecte de données relatives à des
citoyens américains surveillance de
câbles sous marins de télécommunications
inter continental surveillance
d'institutions internationales comme le
conseil européen à bruxelles ou encore
le siège des nations unies
le jeune analyste met alors en garde le
monde contre des programmes de
surveillance en ligne baptisé prisme ou
encore x qui est score il devient alors
un ennemi d'état inculpé au pénal par la
justice américaine pour espionnage et
vols de secrets d'état et encourait
jusqu'à 30 ans de prison alors qu'il
comptait demander l'asile à la
république d'équateur il est bloqué le
23 juin 2013 à l'aéroport de moscou pour
un problème de passeport
il passera un mois avant de demander
l'asile à la russie moscou et répondra
favorablement depuis la justice
américaine ne cesse de réclamer son
extradition en 2013 en pleine campagne
présidentielle
donald trump n'a pas hésité à qualifier
l'informaticien de traîtres en
promettant s'il était élu de le traité
durement obamacare est un désastre et
snowdon est un espion qui devrait être
exécutée
mais s'il pouvait révéler les archives
d'obama je pourrais devenir un grand fan
ce nous donnait un traître est une honte
ne vous y trompez pas il n'est pas un
héros en fait c'est un lâche qui devrait
revenir et faire face à la justice
mais le 13 août dernier lors d'une
interview donnée depuis le bureau ovale
au new york post
les journalistes américains assiste à
une véritable voix
face il y a beaucoup de gens qui pensent
qu'il n'est pas traitée équitablement
je veux dire j'entends ça une
intervention du président américain qui
n'est pas passée inaperçue le principal
intéressé n'a d'ailleurs pas tardé à
réagir sur twitter
la dernière fois que nous avons entendu
une maison blanche envisager une grasse
c'était en 2016
lorsque le même procureur général qui
m'a une fois inculpé a admis que dans
l'ensemble mon travail pour dénoncer le
système inconstitutionnel de
surveillance de masse de l'année ça
avait été un service public
alors pourquoi un tel coup théâtre
doit-on voir dans le rétro pédalage de
donald trump un lien avec la course à la
maison blanche où il simple pique
adressée aux démocrates le 15 août
dernier dans son golf de bedminster dans
le new-jersey le président américain
surprend de nouveau les journalistes en
laissant entendre qu'il pourrait
envisager une grâce beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'il devrait être traité
différemment et d'autres gens pensent
qu'il a fait des choses très mauvaise
je vais y jeter un oeil
l'avocate de snowdon estime lui que la
grâce est inappropriée car son client
n'a commis aucun crime
il souligne même néanmoins une avancée
dans le dossier
je crois que si trump a abordé ce sujet
c'est qu'il partage les principes et les
idéaux de droits et de libertés des
citoyens que snowdon prêche le fait même
que trump est dit cela montre qu'il n'y
ait pas indifférent donc je pense qu'il
va s'occuper de la situation
un espoir pour certains une stratégie de
campagne pour d'autres quoi qu'il en
soit si donald trump venait à lui
accorder la grâce edward snowdon
deviendrait le premier lanceur dallaire
être graciée dans le cadre d'un scandale
d'état